avant que la vidéo commence il faut
savoir que pour la première fois cette
théorie ne se base sur rien du tout à
part une simple idée folle alors prenons
le temps de rêver
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous ne trouvez pas ça bizarre que daisy
soit arrivée dans smash bros ultimate
laissant le dernier des personnages
principaux de l'univers mario tout seul
je veux dire il y à tout le monde
everyone is firent tout l'univers de
mario est là tous les persos principaux
excepté waluigi alors oui dans son
histoire ou à luigi n'est pas un
personnage créé par nintendo eux mêmes
mais plutôt par camelot software car il
fallait trouver un partenaire pour wario
afin de pouvoir faire des matchs double
de tennis ilie l'exact opposé de luigi
tout comme mario les pour mario est donc
vrai que waluigi n'a jamais été trop
portés dans le coeur de nintendo ils
n'ont jamais voulu développer l'histoire
de ce dernier et produire un simple jeu
le concernant ou à luigi est toujours
présent que dans lés spin off où il y a
besoin d'une grande quantité des
personnages de mario mario kart mario
party mario tennis qui d'ailleurs est le
seul jeu qui nous ont fait apprendre
plus sur le personnage car il est très
très doué au tennis enfin bref
mais qu'en est-il de smash bros c'est
tout bête mais pourquoi
everyone is here butt excepté waluigi
yes i'm very good english smash bros
réunit tous les personnages de mario
comme un mario party tennis carte ou et
cetera
il nous manque juste waluigi je vais
reprendre la phrase vous ne trouvez pas
ça bizarre
vous ne trouvez pas ça bizarre que
sakurai a totalement conscience que les
fans réclament de personnages mais ne
fait rien et l' esquive
en fait ce que je veux dire c'est que
nintendo aujourd'hui a totalement
intégré ou à luigi à l'univers de mario
sakurai c'est ce que veulent les fans et
c'est bien évidemment pour ça que nous
avons eues bayonetta cloud riou et
surtout raëd les kings cas rôle qu'ils
étaient des personnages ultra demandé
pour ces deux derniers sur le web
réfléchissez deux minutes waluigi est
complètement devenu un mème tellement il
est quémander son absence a créé une
flopée de vidéos sur internet dont
notamment la mienne qui va se nourrit
dans la masse ceci crée un coup de com
énorme pour le futur jeu de combat et
c'est ce que recherche nintendo en fait
ma vidéo ne se base sur rien de spécial
mais il est certain que sakurai cache
quelque chose et tout n'a pas encore été
dévoilé
super smash bros est une sagaie
réunissant énormément de personnages du
jeu vidéo et se base sur du fan service
car vous adorez les faire combattre vos
personnages préférés
je me souviens avoir acheté brawl quand
j'étais plus enfants car il y avait le
carillon elin qui a ainsi que l'univers
de mario
tout le monde veut waluigi dans ce match
et sakura il peut très certainement nous
faire la surprise d'annoncer waluigi en
personnage jouable en tout dernier pour
hype et les joueurs la veille de la
sortie du jeu
ce serait un coup de com' énorme pour le
jeu mais vraiment énorme vu la hype que
crée le personnage et nintendo en a
totalement conscience alors je vous
arrête tout de suite je sais évidemment
que waluigi a déjà été annoncée dans le
jeu comme trophée aide aux côtés de
michael flynn et j'en passe mais smash
bros n'en est pas à sa première surprise
qui nous dit que ce n'est pas un leurre
pour justement nous tromper j'ai regardé
pas mal de gameplay de smash bros
ultimate
et je n'en ai pas encore vu une seule
fois où à luigi était dans la partie
après peut-être que mes recherches n'ont
pas été aboutis
bref après cela reste un contre argument
majeur au fait qu'il ne sera pas dans
smash tout comme le fait que waluigi est
tellement unique dans l'univers de mario
qu'il ne peut être un combattant échos
comme les daisy avec pitch mais si des
personnages de castlevania sont présents
en personnage jouable cloud riou ou même
snake et j'en passe c'est étrange que
waluigi ne soit qu'un simple trophée
aide
j'aimerais finir cette vidéo sur le
potentiel nouveau mode prévu pour ce
super smash bros ultimate
il faut savoir que sakurai créé ces jeux
smash bros comme si c'était les derniers
à être produit c'est pour ça qu'une team
est réuni tout le monde pour le grand
bien des fans et qu'il est poussé au max
il est sûr à quasiment 100% qu'il
s'agisse du mode histoire comme je
voulais dit sakurai et big n annonce les
nouveautés du jeu au fur et à mesure et
beaucoup d'informations manquent encore
à l'appel
le mode classique a été dévoilé le mode
online évidemment le mode entraînement
bref cette zone verte pixelisé bien
cachés par nintendo et forcément le mode
histoire
pourquoi vouloir à tout prix cacher ce
mode si il ya forcément quelque chose de
grand derrière et je pense que le petit
icône pixelisé est en rapport avec ce
dernier
tout reste encore totalement possible
chauvel n'a était même présent ainsi que
bomberman shadow pourrait répondre à
l'appel
après tout sa présence en tant que
prophète n'est pas présente cela
m'étonnerait qu'ils soient effacées du
jeu je pense que sony corp a donc son
combattant échos je garde toujours
espoir concernant les personnages que
nous avions annoncée après tout kim
carulla été annoncée wolf ice climbers
inkling sans compter et bas les trophées
aide
je vous remercie d'avoir suivi cette
vidéo jusqu'au bout et j'espère qu'elle
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à mettre 1
pouces bleus et partager la vidéo et
vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait
vous pouvez également me soutenir en me
suivant sur twitter où regarder quelques
pubs sur uts iep
bref j'ai hâte d'éclater vos petites
têtes sur super smash bros ultimate que
le lionheart soit avec vous c'était à
rock
[Musique]